[Música]
[Aplausos]
buenas tardes para mí es súper extraño
estar en un ambiente sin un teatro con
un micrófono de la mano y no hacer stand
up no ponerme a hablar huevadas
pero también es un reto para mí es
interesante no solamente pensar en hacer
reír sino en por qué reímos y mucha
gente también va a estar preguntándose
qué tiene que ver esto con banca ahora
para mí también era complicado cómo
puedo relacionar lo que yo hago con la
banca yo ni plata tengo
entonces me di cuenta que hay una
cuestión en está en este mundo bancario
qué está tan íntimamente relacionado con
el capital con el dinero en lo que lo
que yo hago y encontré una relación bien
indirecta pero relación al fin y eso es
el miedo al fracaso en el caso del
dinero es el miedo de no tener dinero en
mi caso desde el miedo al escenario en
silencio al público en silencio entonces
cuando me dijeron que hable de lo que yo
sepa muy bien y que maneje que tenga
muchísima experiencia dije el fracaso
eso es lo que yo sé estén muy bien
entonces
comencé a acordarme cuáles son mis
contactos con el fracaso y como él digo
son varios y muchos empezaron cuando la
gente me recordaba que puedo fracasar
una de las preguntas que más me hacen
cuando le cuento a la gente que hago
stand up que hago monólogos cómicos que
trabajo en comedia es no te da miedo y
si no se ríen qué haces yo hasta ahora
no sé
qué hago cuando no se ríen esto siempre
me toca aprender a improvisar y ver qué
se puede hacer entonces tomando en
cuenta eso yo me di cuenta que hacía
falta un espacio en quito para practicar
estándar
abrimos un espacio de micrófono abierto
en un bar de la ciudad es un espacio
donde la gente que quiere va se sube
prueba cinco minutos de estándar se le
va bien bacán si no le va viendo en
ningún lío porque no es pagado es
completamente gratis es un juego y la
gente lo hace se sube y tiene muchísimo
miedo a fracasar y ha habido gente que
me he dicho a ve no sé si puedo subirme
porque no sé qué vaya a pasar y yo le
digo solamente ten confianza en ti el
tipo se sube eleva pésimo
le va muy mal y nadie se ríe y zumbido
un problema y se baja y está sufriendo
porque fracase porque esa es la esencia
de la comedia le digo ser la parte de la
comedia y parte de la vida del fracaso y
la comedia es la mejor manera que
tenemos para lidiar con el fracaso lo
que tienen atrás de ustedes creo que es
bastante reconocible no es no es ciencia
exacta es la torre inclinada de pisa
cuando me preguntan a mí cómo lidiar con
el fracaso yo siempre les digo es como
hay que pensar la torre inclinada de
pisa yo en una época de mi vida estaba
trabajando de corrector de estilo en un
periódico y tenía que haber tenido
muchísimo tiempo en bus para llegar al
periódico porque era muy lejos y yo
siempre pasaba viendo un poste cerca del
don bosco del norte de quito y el poste
siempre estaba inclinado con los cables
ay cogidos se avisoraba y el desastre
que eso podía causar en el barrio y
nunca dejaba estar inclinado entonces yo
veía eso y siempre pensaba en la torre
inclinada de pisa y ahí es cuando me di
cuenta que la torre inclinada de pisa es
famosa porque está mal hecha
si es que la torre estuviera perfecta
sería una torre cualquiera más si es que
no hubieran inaugurado esa torre y el
momento que inauguraron la torre y shock
y la gente se quedó como
no se cayó
este momento para mí es la relación que
se tiene con el fracaso que el fracaso
puede ser muy bueno pues yo les digo
cuando en mi show de stand up o cuando
abro la torre inclinada de pisa y que
tengo este recuerdo del sector este de
este poste en don bosco yo siempre les
digo así cuando veía los gringos que se
tomaban clásico posando así para todos
reto de la cuestión y veía lleno de
turistas tenía ganas de gritarles
provengan a ecuador
acá todo está mal de hecho
y ya pensaba cómo iba a ser la gira en
ecuador en el puente de mataje
construido hasta la mitad les digo de
barack a codo sinclair a sí mismos se
caiga
al volcán o parte del teleférico no
viene ningún gringo
y una vez que hacía ese chiste a veces
tengo muchas risas a veces no tanto pero
me sorprendió que una vez no solamente
que no tuve muchas risas sino que
después se me acercó un tipo por eso me
dijo tú no puedes reírte de eso
porque no puedes reírte de lo que
estamos mal porque no recuperas lo que
estamos bien porque lo que estamos bien
no es chistoso
porque la gente le tiene miedo al
fracaso a la gente le tiene pavor a no
fracasar no triunfar estamos en una
época donde lo importante es cuánta
plata tienes cuánto ganas cuánto cuánto
cuantos logros y des en tu vida la mejor
foto para facebook es es el fin del
historia increíble esa historia que
tiene full likes hay gente que te
hablando del schering y del engagement
un montón de tu enterado en todo mundo
está compitiendo por eso hay gente como
trump
que te presentan esta noción de que
todos solamente los ganadores valen
cuando la parte de nuestra vida es
también aprender a lidiar con el fracaso
el fracaso una una definición cercana al
fracaso esta idea de no no ser capaz de
cumplir las expectativas que tienen los
demás de ti y sobre todo las relativas
que tienes de ti mismo el fracaso que
más suelen fracasar contigo mismo
entonces cuando yo estoy lidiando con
eso me doy cuenta de que el fracaso en
la comedia es la esencia de su fortaleza
y de su importancia su fortaleza y su
importancia voy a citar a aristóteles
así de culta de esta charla
aristóteles fue uno de los primeros que
trabajó en esta cuestión de diferenciar
los géneros de la tragedia y la comedia
y él cuando se refiere a la comedia dice
que lo cómico es un defecto y una
fealdad que no contiene ni dolor ni daño
del mismo modo que la máscara cómica es
algo feo y deforme pero sin dolor
porque la comedia tiene esta fuerza casi
incomparable no conozco muchas cosas que
tengan la fuerza de la comedia en el
exorcismo en liberarse de nuestros
miedos de nuestras falencias nuestros
defectos es una máscara que demuestra lo
más feo que tenemos pero al ser una
máscara le quita completamente el dolor
coge la realidad y deforma la realidad
para mostrarnos cómo es en un reflejo
deformado hay mucha gente que se sabe
estresar con la cuestión de hasta dónde
es bueno contar un chiste qué tema no y
cómo tocar cualquier tema y cómo tocar
hay que ser lo suficientemente
inteligente para tocarlo adecuadamente y
que cause gracia pero la comedia por más
tensa que sea o por más negra oscura que
sea está ahí para recordarnos quiénes
somos entonces
hay que tomar en cuenta de que no es la
realidad es una realidad deformada así
como la humita no es el choclo es un
choclo cambiado
es una gran comparación
la comedias de estos de una cuestión de
que se tiene que manejar de que
enfrentarte al fracaso
entonces para poder entender y ya como
para estar manejando los mismos
conceptos filosofando un poco de acerca
de acerca de la comedia nos encontramos
con henri bergson que es un filósofo
francés del siglo 19 si los veinte
inicios y el habla el habla seria de
greg y que es lo que nos hace reír lo
que causa la gracia es descubrir la
mecanicidad del alma cuando el alma no
es capaz de adaptarse a su medio
ambiente super darwin a no esto no super
darwin él dice que por ejemplo cuando
vemos allí que está caminando y hay un
poste al frente y él no cambia la
dirección del postes no cambia la
dirección de su trayecto para no
chocarse contra el poste y se da contra
el poste lo que nos causa gracia es
poder ver en esa persona una mecanicidad
que nos altera ante los obstáculos
la comedia te da armas porque te enseña
el camino que no debiste haber tomado al
mismo tiempo que te muestra el camino
que debiste haber tomado te muestra lo
feo para mostrarte la opción de lo bueno
te corrige de alguna manera la comedia
ejerce un poder que corrige las
costumbres la comedia del arte italiana
tenía un lema que es castigar riddle
dolores riéndose cambian las costumbres
ya vamos a volver a eso porque antes
quiero recordar a un otro gran gran
comediante
'miguel de cervantes' la primera novela
de la historia la novela moderna de la
historia está llena de comicidad
el quijote surge porque había un
cansancio general acerca de las novelas
de caballería donde los protagonistas
son héroes que no tienen ninguna
competencia y siempre se levantan sobre
la maldad se quedan con una chica en
nivel hollywood
y el quijote no es así el quijote en su
locura quiere copiar a estos caballeros
quiere ser igual de grande quiere ser
igual de épico y termina golpeado por
molinos que el confundió con gigantes
termina aporreado con campesinos que el
confundió con caballeros termina
golpeado por prostitutas que el
confundió como una dama
el quijote es un libro tan válido una
novela tan importante porque nos
recuerda a los humanos que somos que no
somos caballeros que nos caemos que nos
golpeamos que tenemos un montón de
problemas y que tenemos que luchar
contra eso por eso a mí unas vacaciones
me ha tocado trabajar con banca donde la
donde clientes nuestros como produban
con los dichos no tenemos que
desarrollar campañas para mostrar el
nuevo camino de la de la banca
y me gusta mucho trabajar con clientes
donde tú puedas
trabajar también con comedia dos tienen
una están apuntando un grupo joven y a
los jóvenes les gusta reírse y una cosa
que hemos manejado nosotros en las
campañas de esta comparación entre como
era antes y cómo es ahora por la
cuestión de la banca en línea y todo eso
y trabajar con gente que se da cuenta de
que lo chistoso te hace pensar en lo
serio es muy muy muy interesante por
ejemplo con ellos hemos manejado esta
teoría de comparar lo antiguo con lo
nuevo como conquistaba a nuestros padres
como conquistamos medios los los a los
premien y el que llamado señor sé con
qué estar con teléfono fijo no con
whatsapp o si no poder ponerse a hablar
acerca de la tía que no sabe usar el
whatsapp y te manda demanda violines hip
hop a las 4 de la mañana y tú no tienes
diría que el que está que le está
pasando tu tía
esa señorita tiene esa tía por ejemplo
entonces buscar ese tipo de cosas con un
cliente es súper interesante porque tú
sabes que se da cuenta de que la comedia
es una fuerza de cambio es una manera de
frente a lo que le temes acá digan para
mí que no es un gran ejemplo de eso en
este en esta strip de estar este dibujo
de kilo
básicamente la historia de la muerte que
viene a visitar el enfermo y el enfermo
no sé una jugada extraña que acaba
dejando la muerte embarazada
la muerte se dan cuenta tratar un tema
tan oscuro al que le tenemos tanto miedo
como la muerte y solamente alguien un
comediante como quino puede hacer esto
en la misma manera nosotros de la
naturaleza nos damos cuenta de que la
comedia nos despierta los sentidos lo
que estos están ustedes viendo atrás es
una escena de un documental de national
geographic donde un tiburón blanco se
comen albatros porque los albatros son
animales no muy inteligentes y cuando
están aprendiendo a volar están en el
agua y los tiburones blancos son
animales muy inteligentes reconocen que
esos álvaro están aprendiendo nadar y se
lanzan y se comen pero los albatros como
no tienen mucha memoria a largo plazo se
olvidan rápidamente lo que pasa es que
simplemente se levantan se le combina el
amigo se levanta se vuelve a estar
y se le comen a él
y yo cuando vi eso dije esto es lo que
esto es lo que pasa en el ser humano
cuando no está no está alerta y la
comedia despierta tu sentido de comedia
sorpresa ustedes nunca se van a reír de
un chiste que ya habita en el final para
que un chiste les causa gracia tienen
que pedir que a ver un giro final que
les haga reír
entonces yo cuando vi esto me quedé con
esta imagen de que sí
no aprende de tu fracaso como los
albatros te condenan necesariamente a
ser comido
entonces cuando nos piden campañas de
banca así que debemos decir sí pero
porque no hablemos de las cosas malas
hablemos del fracaso y te dicen probemos
te das cuenta de que la comedia es una
gran gran manera un gran vehículo para
que el fracaso llegue a tu vida y te
enseñe que el ser humano que eres un
quijote que te puedes equivocar que te
puedes quedar en silencio frente una
sala que es un chiste tuyo nueva causa
gracias que una campaña no te funciona
que una inversión te callas
y eso es muy útil en la vida porque
estamos estamos muy apagados con esta
idea de de redes de ser los más
populares y de ganar todo el tiempo
entonces les digo que para mí ha sido
muy chévere reflexionar acerca de la
comedia dejar un poco el estándar y
reflexionar acerca de qué es lo que
hacen reír y qué tan útil es texto de
jalarse y arriesgarme a que no se rían o
que no entiendan o que no haya ninguna
reacción del público pero es bacán
porque eso siempre me da algo más y yo
aprendo de eso y aprender el fracaso es
lo más importante según yo así que le
digo muchísimas gracias y recuerden que
a veces no está tan mal torcerse gracias
[Aplausos]